now with more is the author of here's
the deal uh number one new york times
bestseller kellyanne conway along with
the host of the larry elder show for
epic the epic times larry elder and
former white house chief of staff mark
meadows kellyanne you got to love this
larry state of california now i'm
blaming larry he should have been
elected out there this wouldn't be
happening
this this problem would be solved let's
put it that way but here they have all
the natural resources they're chasing
people out of the state for the first
time in 170 years they're telling you
cool your home up to 4 p.m in the
afternoon then put the ac up to 78.
okay you're gonna be sweating in your
own bedroom and you won't be able to
sleep and you probably can't even use a
fan uh and how's that working with
electric vehicles kellyanne
shawn i'm coming to you from california
and the people here are all abuzz about
these mandates a couple of things let's
stop picking on working well if you're
in california kellyanne may pop out of
the screen
if the lights go out we'll know why
we'll know why
so let's stop picking on working people
first they have to pay for the harvard
educated doctors lawyers and business
people now they're being told when they
get home from a hard day's work at four
pm they're ready to open their fridge
cook dinner for their kids
fire up the air conditioner they can't
touch any of that don't open your fridge
don't air condition your house and don't
cook for your family don't do the
laundry it makes absolutely no sense but
listen i think newsome 2024 his platform
is starting to take shape an open border
in southern california the streets of
san francisco where he was mayor before
he was lieutenant governor and governor
littered with needles and feces homeless
encampments everywhere
ships and containers off in the pacific
ocean waiting to unload here and now
this uh look it's beyond hypocrisy the
face of this democratic party starts
right here in california kamala harris
nancy pelosi gavin newsom those liar big
mouths schiff and swalwell maxine
mortars and everybody should take note
this is what the democratic party wants
the rest of us to be and in addition to
being hypocritical and hurting the wrong
people
gavin newsom can't get his story
straight he took the kids out of the
schools for almost two years
he made them sit behind a computer in
everybody's kitchens
and pretend that screen time is school
time now sean you have kids leaving the
schools early or canceling classes now
in places like san diego denver philly
all across here in different places in
california because they don't have air
conditioning do you know that congress
passed billions of dollars in coveted
relief to make sure there was proper
ventilation air conditioning and these
kids are out of school again now you
know why gavin newsom's in-laws moved to
florida voted for ron desantis gave
money to ron desantis and are now
registered republicans it started right
in the news and household
yes that's true larry all right it's
your state so buddha judge has said it
grand home has said it biden has said it
harris has said it that they want energy
independence with renewables and they
want americans to think about buying the
twenty thousand dollar uh extra cost
electric vehicle that's powered by
fossil fuels okay
explain to me why it's okay to import
oil from the iranians because they want
to do this deal or the venezuelans or
beg the saudis and kiss the ass of the
crown prince or beg opec that keeps
rejecting calls to increase production
why is it okay to get energy from them
and not produce it domestically nobody's
been able to answer that question for me
well i consider that to be a rhetorical
question uh sean you know the answer
it's not okay uh and look remember when
jean-pierre was asked whether or not joe
biden even owns an ev and she danced
around it it is clear that the
commander-in-chief who wants everybody
to go green doesn't even own an ev and
i'm here in california sean and it's
even worse some people not everybody got
texts from the state urging people not
to watch television during peak hours
and to either play cards or to write a
book i kid you not and only 1.9 of all
of the 30 million vehicles in california
are evs and as you know shortly after
this
mandate that would ban all new sales of
gasoline-powered cars effective 2035
they said don't plug in your ev during
peak hours imagine when there are 20 or
30 million evs here in california and
finally sean it wouldn't matter if all
of a sudden california went to zero
emissions it wouldn't matter if the
united states went to zero emissions or
canada or germany it wouldn't have any
effect at all on the planet because of
the co2 spilled out by china and by
india that are building coal power
plants every single day the whole thing
is absurd it is a scam the likes of
which i've never seen before
you know mark meadows donald trump did
something i think one of his greatest
accomplishments as president he got us
to energy independence for the first
time in 75 years uh he left office
america was a net exporter of energy i
would like to return to that and even
take it a step further and become the
single most energy dominant country in
the world and i would like to provide
all the energy needs of all of our
western european allies and i think that
would make america rich again lower
everybody's tax base and and everybody
would prosper and it would create how
many millions of high-paying career jobs
in the energy sector
well it would make america great again
you know congress is real certain that
they need to do investigations perhaps
they need to do an investigation on how
we went from energy dominance uh to
energy beggars in two years listen
this reminds me of the jimmy carter days
you know if you remember his energy
speech and he he said well you just have
to get used to it we we just have to go
this way but it really is all about them
doubling down on their policy destroying
our resources jacking up the prices and
then suggesting that you're the problem
they need to look in the mirror i mean
you know maybe the question is
is that there i wonder if there's been
a call made to the french laundry
restaurant that allowed governor newsom
to not wear a mask to say you need to
set it up to 78 degrees on your
thermostat you know perhaps all this
travel that we're all thinking that it's
governor newsome going to go and
challenge joe biden he's just looking
for a state where he can cool off
well said so kellyanne our friend robert
haley of trafalgar came out with a poll
56.8 of respondents watched that speech
in philly with the deep dark red
eerie background although if you watched
on cnn it was a pretty pink they changed
the color
but anyway that's
56.8 said it was a dangerous escalation
and rhetoric and they said it was
designed to incite conflict among
americans
as far as the economy goes a majority of
americans according to gallup 56 percent
again now say price increases are
causing financial hardship for their
households two-thirds of americans are
now living paycheck to paycheck and more
than a third of working families cannot
afford simple basic needs after they cut
out everything they can possibly cut out
now the question is how did we go from a
prosperous economy to this mess in 19
months
i thought cnn's pink hue was a lovely
gender reveal i just didn't understand
it but uh on this had to be with the
people i got to tell you in focus groups
and in polling what they're saying is
they're very scared there's a lot of
fear and frustration out there you know
shawn and gentlemen it started out with
gas and groceries but now it is utility
bills it's the rent it's the mortgage
it's the car payment the tuition payment
the student loan payment everyday life
has become increasingly unaffordable
under joe biden and kamala harris he's
taken away our national security our
border security economic security and
frankly our public safety just our
physical security and he didn't erase
any of that by going and castigating and
denigrating half of the country you know
we on the republican party conservative
movement we're going to attack issues
he's going to attack individuals and
everybody's grandmother was right
big minds talk about big issues and big
challenges small minds talk about other
people and that's what joe biden is
doing i've never seen somebody try to
engage voters by enraging them by
alienating them and it's not going to
work because his numbers are still under
water and people still don't have the
warmth for him see him as inspiring as a
leader compassionate a man with a plan
has the vision and the acuity to get the
job done he knows when the republicans
take the house and jim jordan gets that
gavel his son by hunter biden will be
the first investigating i guarantee you
that the country will be for that
because that guy flew around on
government taxpayer-funded aircraft
shaking down govern governments and
people of other companies he had no
energy experience his father has no
energy it's a big hot mess the
republicans will win
particularly in the house
larry how does this impact the midterms
well i think it's going to affect the
midterms the top two issues are crime uh
and uh inflation and then you've got
throw in throwing gas prices people are
very very angry uh and this top down
stuff at least in this in this last
speech john he didn't refer to americans
as semi-fast as the way he did a few uh
days earlier now what is the definition
of fascism socialism is when government
owns a means of production fascism is
when the government allows you to own
the means of production but tells you
how to run them we're talking about
california they just set up a board that
will establish what the what the wages
are for fast food workers imagine that a
board telling you what your wages ought
to be and they say they're going to be a
minimum of 22 dollars a month so again
fascism is when you are allowed to run
your business but the government tells
you how to run it outrageous and mark
will this be a driving issue will these
be driving issues during the election
and do you see republicans you see a
wave election that many are predicting i
hate to make those predictive
predictions myself well i i hate to make
the predictions but what you look at are
the are the falling poll numbers of joe
biden you look at the way that they're
not learning from those following poll
numbers they're just uh you know
continuing to double down triple down on
all their failed policies you know even
when you go to pennsylvania and you you
talk to the pennsylvania voters there
they know what honest and true is and it
wasn't coming from the lips of our
commander-in-chief
that currently occupies 1600
pennsylvania avenue all right mark larry
kellyanne thank you all hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else